and we are taking a live look right now
us 95 at horizon drive where there were
some major traffic delays this morning
due to construction christian joins us
now in studio with what caused this mess
and maybe if this could happen again
christian what'd you find out well
kirsten i reached out to ndot today and
the traffic delay from this morning was
due to the lack of communication between
them and the contractor las vegas paving
endot was not aware that sensors were
being installed during the morning rush
hour
the construction currently underway
involves the repaving of a 10 mile
stretch of asphalt which is about 15
years old that will be replaced by a
rubber material that can only be done
during certain temperatures adrian
packer with ndot says crews have been in
the process but what's taking so long is
filling in all the cracking that happens
on the cement bridge decks along the
roadway the project itself should be
done by the end of the year
so as long as you know we want to get
the uh
the rubberized asphalt placed before the
end of the year again now we're racing
against the temperatures packer says the
contractor was installing sensors this
morning that forced traffic to a single
lane to collect information like speed
and traffic count
well i'm told this should not happen
again this was all lack of communication
from both parties and we were told that
no one would
be facing any fines either now the
project is expected to be completed by
the end of this year guys